let's address the the number two in the
timorous trifecta of predictions here
everyone going bonkers for final fantasy
because worlds of final fantasy is those
little characters aren't cute fine in
little tiny heads up against other
little pony where she B's man she's like
a beautiful you know franchise everyone
loves and everyone just sort of SAT up a
little bit and then this came on
everyone just felt bad for the world of
final there wasn't world of final
fantasy yeah how do you feel about for
the developers of this they've been
reduced to a gag now like a setup your
setup to a punchline I'm sorry but with
final fantasy remake and those cutscenes
uh you who can stand toe-to-toe with
that I mean we saw I don't know I final
fantasy seven I don't have a like giant
outpouring on the style before I played
it a little bit but everyone there just
losing their minds everyone around the
world you know Final Fantasy 7 remake
crazy happening and it looks like
they've actually put in some effort yes
which is surprising like you think they
just do like a standard shot-for-shot
remake type thing yeah it looks like
they've they've added a little more
depth to the narrative the way the the
kind of the narrator was talking about
the stuff happening in the city it looks
like they've they've kind of upped the
story and made it boy into the modern
day with better writing and kind of
presentation and characters when I kind
of thought let's see what the gameplay
is because like we were expecting an HD
remake like an HD remake of what is
essentially an isometric turn-based
action games are different if they end
up like doing this in the engine that
the new ones in or even something like a
3d engine oh yes I mean that is that is
a good point like what is that gameplay
gonna because final fantasy and Square
Enix has moved away from turn-based
quite oh yes definitely so is this gonna
be a turn-based game or is gonna be
something closer to like Final Fantasy
15 I'm hard so I kind of thing wears
more action focus did say remake yeah
yeah I reckon it will probably be a lot
more action focus the way kingdom hearts
is but I'm down for that like I'd rather
not play another turn based version of
the same game just numbers but yeah
looks looks pretty amazing finally
everyone can stop moaning about yeah
it's happening very few games why not
about that yeah I know it's like Sony's
just knocked them all down yeah let's
just move on before a yesterday and then
Sony just did basically all of them than
today Final Fantasy 7 remake yeah it
seemed like it said debut on PlayStation
4 so might be a xbox version coming soon
maybe with a pc version yeah